We said we need to ROB in order to have precise exceptions, and
also to be able to easily recover from Branch mispredictions. So
let's see how that happens. Suppose we have a program that reaches a branch, and
suppose that our prediction was that the program will continue here and
fetch these three instructions. Although in fact the program branches. So,
this three instructions will be executed in our branch misprediction.
Let's say what happens in this program, you know [UNKNOWN] and
the registers. First, we will issue the LO here, It's output is the R1,
so at the beginning of all of these the ROB is empty. The issue and
commit point are the same, and. That, let's say that there are no instruction.
At the beginning of all of this, let's say that there are no instructions, so
the RAT is just pointing to the registers, and the issue and
commit point in the ROB are the same. Meaning that the ROB is empty,
all of the entries are free. Now let's see what happens when we issue the load.
We move the issue point to here. The load produces R1.
An R1 here in the RAT is made to point to the ROB 1 entry. When
we issue the branch, it produces no output,
and thus we don't need to rename anything and the issue pointer moves here.
Next what happens, we will issue instructions. That, shouldn't have been issued.
But the [UNKNOWN] doesn't know that yet, so it's just going to do it anyway. So
this add here writes to R2. And it gets the next ROB entry here.
So the R2 entry is going to point to ROB3. And then this multiply here.
Is going to write R3. And that R3 is going to ROB4. And then
the divide is going to again write to R2. And that means that the answer for R2,
in the RAT will be changed from pointing to the add to pointing to the divide.
Which is ROB5, and of course after all of this issuing is done,
our issue point is now here. And we have five instructions in our prompt.
Now suppose that this LO takes a long time to produce a value for
example because it's a cash miss. This branch depends on the loads, we've cannot
complete until the load is done, and this add also co-depends on the load and it
cannot complete until the load is done. But this multiply here can begin because
R3 and R4 are not produced by any of these instructions. So this multiply,
might produce a value for example 15 and originally it would
write it to the registers, and at that point after the branch misprediction, but
this multiply can compute its value because R3 and R4 might be ready,
they're not produced many of the previous instructions. So, the value of 15 when
the multiply finishes, would have been written to the registers, and
then, we don't know how to undo the multiplication once we discover that
the branch have been mispredicted. In our [INAUDIBLE] base processor,
the result of the multiplication goes into its. ROB entry,
and it's marked as done. Once this multiply produces a value,
the divide can begin. And let's say that the divide is producing a value of 2,
and it might also be done before the load returns. So now we
have a situation where these two instructions would have updated registers, and
done permanent damage. But in a raw based processor,
all they did was update the raw [INAUDIBLE]. The registers are still unmodified